The series of incidents that took place this time, who planned to kill the Attitude Hero who possesses a false star weapon and is the savior of the world, was
dealt with by the Yuko Pope on the spot
.
The loathsome thing is that the first princess of Orto also
colluded with Soukyo.
No,
they didn't even try
to kill Sanyusha.
[Applause]
og That's this post
[Laughter]
You conspired with Kyoto to kill Melty and become the 1st place in the succession k
for that reason  The Hero of the Shield was turned into a kidnapper, and
Melky set fire to the fleeing mountain,
isn't it?
Mardi I tried it, if it's an urgent recruitment, I'll have a left and right Kyoto arrangement.I
summoned the posture hero at once while I was away.Because I
absolutely needed the strength of the hero to counter that dreadful licking.
I'm in a pinch that shouldn't be violated
That's right
.